[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages guten abend
und willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick
an diesem sonntag an meiner seite ist
wieder norbert leben für den sport 200
von mir und das sind unsere themen heute
erleichterung in den
überschwemmungsgebieten die befürchteten
unwetter blieben aus debatte über corona
impfung cdu-chef laschet spricht sich im
zdf-sommerinterview gegendruck auf
ungeimpfte aus und zweimal bronze bei
olympia lena henkel und tina punzel
werden dritte im synchron springen auch
die deutschen bogenschützen holen
überraschend eine medaille
wir beginnen wieder in den flutgebieten
dort herrscht für den moment eine
gewisse erleichterung weil die nacht
weitgehend trocken war noch mehr
überschwemmungen blieben den menschen
erspart was bleibt sind erschöpfung und
verzweiflung an seinem stern berichtet
als die sonne kommt heute morgen ein
kleines aufatmen keine neuen schlimmen
regenmengen wirklich durchatmen aber
kann niemand im katastrophengebiet das
leid die zerstörung die existenzsorgen
sind viel zu groß
mega anstrengend das jetzt über eine
woche jeden tag so viele stunden
unterwegs
ja das ist noch nicht angekommen von der
psyche her ist noch nicht so richtig
angekommen
christina schmidt ist krankenschwester
in bad neuenahr-ahrweiler
das ist ihr elternhaus schwer verwüstet
von der flut hier muss sie helfen ihre
kinder versorgen und geld verdienen
sie arbeitet bei einem mobilen
pflegedienst durch das chaos zu den
patienten viele brauchen jetzt noch viel
mehr unterstützung und auch zuspruch
brauchen sicherheit haben dass die
soldaten auf den straßen zur hilfe da
sind und eben nicht ihnen was böses
wollen
auf den straßen wird weiter vor allem
geräumt müll und schuttberge werden
weggeschafft damit die lkw besser
durchkommen gilt seit heute eine neue
allgemeinverfügung zum beispiel in bad
neuenahr einfach so rein dürfen nur noch
anwohner und einsatzkräfte
sind sie anwohner freiwillige helfer
freiwillige helfer es sind viele sollen
nur noch koordiniert mit shuttle bussen
kommen
platz schaffen in den flut regionen etwa
hier an der aa in rheinland pfalz aus
der mit baggern die geröllmassen
entfernt werden das wasser soll wieder
schneller abfließen man will vorbereitet
sein sollte es doch wieder heftiger
regnen in den katastrophengebieten im
westen von deutschland
die spendenbereitschaft ist nach wie vor
enorm vor ort und bei der zdf
spendenaktionen da sind mittlerweile
fast 41 millionen euro zusammengekommen
diese spenden konto hat das
aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe
eingerichtet die iban lautet de 65 104
106 100 104 106 100 stichwort zdf
hochwasser weitere informationen finden
sie unter spenden zdf.de und im zdf text
auf seite 8 190
auch wenn die deutschen flutgebiete in
der nacht weitgehend verschont blieben
gewitter mit starkregen gab es trotzdem
vor allem im südwesten deutschlands mit
überfluteten straßen und kellern auch in
belgien gab es heftige wolkenbrüche vor
allem in den regionen in denen
vergangene woche 36 menschen in dem
unwetter ums leben gekommen waren
diesmal wurde niemand verletzt
allerdings war das belgische
krisenzentrum vor weiterem regen
jetzt zu coruna ungeimpfte müssen bei
steigenden infektionszahlen mit weiteren
einschränkungen rechnen dass hat
kanzleramtsminister helge braun
angekündigt der bild am sonntag sagte er
das könne auch bedeuten dass restaurant
und kinobesuche selbst für getestete
ungeimpfte nicht mehr möglich wären
cdu-chef und kanzlerkandidat laschet
hält das im zdf-sommerinterview für
keine gute idee
mathis feldhoff es ist armin laschet
erst das sommerinterview als
cdu-parteichef ein job der auch immer
wieder dazu bestimmt ist die eigenen
leute im zaum zu halten
den neuesten vorstoß in der korona
debatte von kanzleramtschef helge braun
kassiert der kanzlerkandidat der union
heute gleich mal braun hatte der bild am
sonntag gesagt geimpfte würden künftig
definitiv mehr rechte haben als
ungeimpft ich halte nichts von innen
pflicht
und halte auch nichts davon auf menschen
indirekt druck zu machen in einem
freiheitlichen staat gibt es
freiheitsrechte nicht nur für bestimmte
gruppen mehr tempo sollen die durch das
hochwasser verschärfte debatte um die
klimapolitik allerdings früher aus der
kohle auszusteigen wie markus söder
fordert hält der cdu-chef insbesondere
für ostdeutschland für falsch ich finde
politik muss verlässlich sein man kann
nicht letztes jahr sagen es ist jetzt
dieses 2038 und dann fängt man wieder
mit neuen daten an deshalb finde ich
sollten wir im zeitplan bleiben ein
politikverständnis dass laschet als
grund qualifikation fürs kanzleramt
versteht dass er heute allerdings nur
von einer minderheit als kanzlertauglich
erachtet wird stört ihn nicht
das sind schon große fußstapfen die
angela merkel nach 16 jahren
regierungserfahrung hinterlässt aber ich
erinnere mich manchmal an ihre
anfangszeit
da hat sie auch noch vieles lernen
müssen für seinen fauxpas das lachend
während des besuchs des
bundespräsidenten im flutgebiet
entschuldigt sich laschet heute erneut
es war blöd sein
das ganze sommerinterview mit armin
laschet sehen sie direkt nach uns jetzt
der blick auf die korona zahlen
das robert koch institut registrierte
1387 neuinfektionen
das sind 95 mehr als vergangenen sonntag
vier todesfälle kamen binnen 24 stunden
hinzu die bundesweite sieben tage
incidents steigt leicht auf jetzt 13,8
ein jahr corona zwangspause die gab es
auch auf dem grünen hügel in bayreuth
doch seit einer stunde laufen die
richard wagner festspiele wieder unter
strengen corona regeln und mit einer
echten premiere zum ersten mal in 145
jahren steht eine frau am dirigentenpult
die 43 jährige ukrainerin oxana linie
zur eröffnung gibt es den fliegenden
holländer und natürlich viel prominenz
barbara lueg
diesmal strömen sie etwas anders hinein
in diese mythische welt des richard
wagner dezenter schaulauf auch ohne
roten teppich neben an die food trucks
und strengste hygieneregeln
doch die kanzlerin ist verlässlich da
und weitere gut 900 premieren gäste
die festspielchefin meldet sich online
premiere heute also mit dem fliegenden
holländer
[Musik]
doch während der kapitän auf der bühne
in ewiger unrast nach erlösung sucht
steht die eigentliche sensation
unsichtbar unterhalb der bühne im tiefen
orchestergraben oksana lynes die erste
frau hier am dirigentenpult ein
historischer moment eine riesensache für
sie selbst auch die aufgaben sind
dieselben die partitur oder die aufgaben
die wagner für uns gestellt hat werden
dadurch nicht leichter oder schwerer so
oder so auf seiner bühne tut den
festspielen als signal jetzt schon gut
und am ende ist dann noch eine schöne
nachricht es gibt tatsächlich noch ein
paar restkarten freude in tokio norbert
heute gab es die erste medaille für
deutschland zweimal bronze fünf frauen
sei dank medaillen nummer eins gab es
beim wasserspringen im
synchron-wettbewerb vom drei-meter-brett
für tina punzel und lena häntzschel der
größte erfolg in der karriere der
viermalige europameisterin und ihrer
partner an
volle konzentration für den letzten und
entscheidenden sprung er gelingt nahezu
perfekt tina punzel und lena henschel
können es anfangs kaum glauben sie haben
bronze gewonnen
fünf jahre haben sie für diesen moment
trainiert haben wir uns auch angeguckt
gefreut noch kurz gewartet bis auf der
anzeigetafel stand und dann ja was
einfach nur freude erleichterungen glück
und so eine mischung aus allem
der sieg ging an die favoritinnen aus
china zweiter wurden die kanadierinnen
für den deutschen schwimm-verband ist es
in diesem wettbewerb die erste olympia
medaille seit 2008
und bronze medaille nummer zwei gab es
für die deutschen frauen um lisa unruhe
im bogenschießen die erste team olympia
medaille seit sydney 2000 der letzte und
entscheidende satz dem teamwettbewerb
bogenschützin lisa unruh muss die zehn
treffen für eine olympia medaille
tief einatmen konzentrieren keine nerven
zeigen und volltreffer der perfekte
schuss aus 70 metern unruhe und ihre
teamkolleginnen michelle gruppen und
charlene schwarz haben es geschafft fünf
zu eins gegen belarus bronze in tokio
der jubel riesig so groß dass sie heute
noch feiern wollen corona konform wie
sie ankündigten
und hier weitere highlights des zweiten
wettkampftages wir beginnen mit dem
mühsam erkämpften 3 2-sieg des deutschen
fußballteams gegen saudi arabien die
deutsche elf stand mächtig unter druck
denn die partie gegen saudi arabien
musste gewonnen werden um ins
viertelfinale einzuziehen
schließlich gelang felix utoquai in der
75 minute der führungstreffer zum 3 2
somit war die weitere qualifikation
gesichert
auf klare medaillenkurs in die deutschen
dressurreiterinnen die darbietungen auf
höchstem niveau wurden für isabell werth
auf belarus und ihren beiden
mannschaftskolleginnen mit platz eins
bewertet damit startet deutschland im
mannschaftsfinale im straßenradrennen
der frauen eine sensation olympisches
gold für anna kiesenhofer aus österreich
eine außenseiterin die 30 jährige konnte
ihren vorsprung bis zum ziel verteidigen
und das war es auch schon vom sport
dankeschön das wetter bleibt turbulent
der deutsche wetterdienst warnt vor
schweren unwettern in teilen bayerns und
sachsen anhalts die weiteren aussichten
bei einem mix aus sonne und wolken gibt
es vor allem im norden und südwesten
schauer und teils kräftige gewitter im
norden ist die unwettergefahr am größten
die temperatur steigt auf 22 bis 28 grad
christian sievers begrüßte im heute
journal um vortritt vor 10 wir danken
für ihr interesse wünschen ihnen einen
guten start in die neue woche und sagen
tschüss bis morgen wenn sie mögen